>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
[ Silence ]
>> Mekaella Vailu'u:
Hello, everyone.
Seeing a lot of familiar faces,
so thank you for coming again.
This will be our third and
final event that I have planned.
If this is your first
one that you've attended,
I wanted to take a second
to introduce myself.
I'm a student from EKU which
is Eastern Kentucky University.
My major is deaf studies,
and the ITP that we have.
Political science is my minor.
So, yes, I'm an interpreting
student at Eastern.
During my tenure at the
Library, I have hosted
and planned three events.
They're listed on the board.
The first dealt with technology
and how it influenced deaf
culture in the deaf world.
And then, second, it was
Divia [phonetic] Art.
And then, third, we'll be talking
about preserving deaf culture.
There will be a fourth
that is not related
to deaf culture, but
it is another event.
It will focus on my
family heritage and lineage
which is of the Samoan culture.
A Congress woman will be coming,
and she will be a part of the event.
Her name is Amata, and she will be
coming during that presentation.
For today, we invited
Max Williamson.
He used to actually
be one of my teachers,
and he moved to the DC area.
And so very honored to have him
come and to talk about his culture,
his experience, and his community.
Without further ado, Mr. Williamson.
>> Max Williamson: Hello.
So like she said, previously
I was an employee
at Eastern Kentucky University.
I graduated from Gallaudet with
my master's, and right now I'm
on my track to get my PhD.
I do work with a lot of
deaf/blind consumers,
and that is my specialty right now.
So recently Mekaella asked me if
I would come and do a presentation
and just kind of comment on
how to preserve deaf culture.
And I'm really honored
to be here and meet many
of you that have come today.
So today's focus is
going to be on how
to preserve American deaf culture.
And within that, I'm going to
touch on a few subtopics as well,
and we'll go through that as
the presentation goes along.
So many of you might be
asking, what is deaf culture?
And really deaf culture consists
of many different cultures.
There's black deaf culture,
deaf/blind, deaf culture, LGBT.
And so there are many
facets within deaf culture,
but one thing that we all have
in common is that we're deaf.
So at the same time, the black deaf
community has their own language
variances as well as the
deaf/blind community.
So deaf culture can, in some
ways, be very all consuming.
So right now you are going to have
a chance to see George Veditz.
This is the his sign name.
And I'm just going to show a short
clip of it, about one minute.
Just so that you can
kind of get an idea
of what this looked
like way back then.
And this was recorded in 1913.
It was the first time that
ASL was ever recorded.
It's a short clip.
[ Background Sounds ]
So I actually made a mistake.
Sorry, it was on the August 1913.
[ Background Sounds ]
I'm not sure if you can see it.
Let's try to dim the lights.
Is that any better?
[ Silence ]
If you're curious about the video,
you can access this link
on Gallaudet's website.
We were having problems before
connecting it with the PowerPoint,
but if you're interested
in finishing the video,
you can find that at Gallaudet.
So the next slide we're going to
talk about the Milan conference,
and that happened in 1880 in Italy.
And what this was was there
was a conference that decided
that deaf language and community
and culture would not be
included in education.
And so Veditz recorded this video
to point out that we do need
to preserve the language.
And so that's why we
recorded the video in 1913.
And Veditz felt that
a lot of the jobs
that deaf individuals were
holding were starting to be lost,
and he predicted that
eventually ASL would be gone.
Sorry, I'm allowing the
interpreter to catch up.
So his purpose was to preserve it.
So here you see a picture of
Alexander Graham Bell, AG Bell.
And you know him as the man
who invented the telephone.
But actually that was a
mistake after he was working
with the Milan conference and
he agreed with oral education,
he wasn't too supportive
of sign language.
Even Veditz talked about
the oppression in his video.
And so the suppression
of sign language.
And he felt that sign language was
important, and that it was a part
of deaf culture and
that it was something
that needed to be continued.
Alexander Graham Bell
had a deaf wife, and so,
and she actually felt similar to AG
Bell in supporting oral education.
In fact, she herself was
oral, and she thought
that everyone else
should be the same.
[ Silence ]
So NAD, the National
Association of the Deaf,
they did more historical
research for AG Bell.
And currently NAD is near
Gallaudet University.
So I just want to go back a
little bit and mention Veditz
and that he's one of the
grandfathers of deaf culture
as well as Laurent Clerc.
And still to this day, they
really affect deaf culture
and Laurent Clerc came from France,
and then you see this
development of sign language.
And so the video that we showed, the
language is a little bit different.
And so it's similar
to English and that
as the language develops you see
some changes and the influence
of culture changes and advancements
in technology, and things like that.
So we really do value both of them,
both Veditz and Laurent Clerc.
So how do we preserve culture?
There's two ways.
One, through advocacy with
organizations such as NAD,
the National Association of Deaf.
There's RID, and they do
a lot of advocacy work
with the deaf community,
hard of hearing individuals.
They're very supportive.
DHH and Deaf and Hard of Hearing
Commission are very similar.
Each state has their own commission
that works within the state,
so those are very similar.
So there is KCDHH, I
think Texas has one.
So each of the states
has their own DHH.
And then there's LEAD K [phonetic].
And that is Language Education
Acquisition of Deaf Children.
So you can also preserve
through actions.
If you notice the first
point is Deafhood.
[ Background Sounds ]
And Deafhood does collaborations
and workshops
and they hold a lot
of training events.
And so they have two focuses.
They focus within the community
and sharing about deaf experience,
and then they also have
a more general focus
on just educating people
on Deafhood.
And now there's the grass
roots movement, DGM.
Oh, there's a question.
The question was?
Do you mind explaining what
the grass roots movement is?
[ Silence ]
The grass roots movement is based
on people who are very immersed
in deaf culture and who have
experienced that oppression
and oddism throughout
their deaf walk of life.
And so this is now a formal
organization that touches
on all of their experiences.
So the grass roots is actually part
of Deafhood, and deaf could be used
as a general word to describe just
the life of somebody who's deaf
and their deaf experience.
And the grass roots movement
kind of shows that, you know,
we might be deaf, but we
have all of these skills,
and we're capable of doing a lot.
And I actually put this one
down a little bit wrong.
[ Background Sounds ]
And this one focuses on teaching
ablism within the culture
and promoting all of the things
that we are actually able to do.
And then these last two, I
mean, these are very popular,
they're used a lot, and I will
expand on both the hashtag
and the vlog in just a little bit.
So and these aren't all of
the pathways to advocacy.
There are many more
ways to get involved,
and you can do lot more research
and find many advocacy
groups that are available.
So here are a few things that I
think would be helpful to know.
And I just found a few pictures
just to kind of explain each one.
The picture over here on
your left is a picture
of the first deaf school that
was established in America,
it's called the American
school for the deaf.
It's in Connecticut.
And then this one here on
the bottom is a deaf club.
And right now, unfortunately, we
see a lot of deaf clubs closing,
and there's not as
much socialization.
And then we notice also that a
lot of the students aren't going
to deaf schools, they're
actually being mainstreams,
and then now we have the interpreter
education programs and degrees.
And then this picture up here on
top is a picture of tactile signing,
and that can be done with
deaf/blind or deaf people
who have a loss of
vision or low vision.
And it's another subset of
language within the community.
And it's still prevalent today.
So and we have deaf/blind clubs
as well where they get together
and share information
and talk about advances
in technology and things like that.
And so there's a lot
of different groups.
There's a question
from the audience.
He will copy sign.
[ Silence ]
So the question is asking about
deaf clubs and how it's the comment
on how there are many
in Maryland and DC
because now they have
happy hours [laughs].
[ Background Sounds ]
So happy hours are like
a get together, right.
So we do see the closure
of deaf clubs,
and they're just kind
of disappearing.
But the language and the culture is
still prevalent, it still exists.
And so you see the switch of
focus to maybe happy hours in bars
or restaurants, things like that,
different establishments
around the DC area.
But those are still places that
deaf individuals can gather.
As well as provide exposure
to people who are hearing
and haven't seen sign language, they
now see people signing at a table,
and that provides a
source of interest for them
to learn or to possibly join in.
And then we can kind of expose them
to our language and our culture
and show them that this is
something that's worth preserving,
and we really do tend to welcome
people into our culture in that way.
[ Background Sounds ]
So what happens when kef
culture is preserved?
You know, we can have kind of
a forward looking view on this.
Right here, a lot of people know.
Or before I mention LEAD K, Nyle
DiMarco, he's involved with LEAD K.
And major advocate of
children and language
and culture exposure
at an early age.
So we see a lot of advocacy.
He's from, in California
they recently passed a law
that required language
acquisition for students
that were deaf, and that they would.
It was about a month ago.
And all of these people were worked,
they had a collaborative
effort to all work together.
Nyle, he won America's
Next Top Model.
And everybody had such
a great exposure to ASL
and to culture at that time.
Now, he's on the other show,
Dancing with the Stars.
And that's the continued exposure
that, no, the language is not gone
and that the advocacy still exists.
And so they did pass that law,
and then he was an advocate
of that bill because it was passed.
And Iowa as well passed
a piece of legislation.
A question, who was that?
That's Nyle, and he has a sign name.
[ Silence ]
So the comment from the audience
was that Nyle DiMarco is his name.
There is a foundation that was just
established, and he set that up
that would provide resource
and materials for people
for hearing individuals
to how to work with people
that are deaf and students.
Similar to how AG Bell had written
an article about, he was hearing
who decided how education
should happen
for individuals that are deaf.
And that we would see a decrease
in the language and exposure.
But now Nyle has spoken
in opposition of that.
He's signing on TV, he's
signing in the media,
and along with his foundation shows
the importance of the preservation.
So he is the modern day
Veditz, and that deaf children
with hearing parents that we
should encourage them to sign.
It's the same with deaf parents who
have hearing children that the more
and more that we expose them to
this language and that the language,
that they can succeed
in the same ways.
So it's the preservation
of the culture
and the preservation
of the language.
So a lot of AG Bell had disseminated
some incorrect information
about the importance of making sure
that we do keep this language alive.
So these are just more and
more news and there's the guy
in the corner called Moth Man.
We have I-News, deaf publications,
and we're seeing a lot more and more
of the education and the
information sharing that's happening
because of the integration
of social media
and its true take off
in our society.
You know, we have Facebook,
Twitter, vlogs.
And I had mentioned vlogs
before that we're making sure
that the language there
is able to be kept.
And it's not disappearing.
Because we have our
online resources,
we're able to teach children and
have them exposed to a wide range
of language and a wide
range of styles of language.
We have Deaf Nation.
They have different events that
happen and booths all set up.
They're open to the public.
People are all welcome to
come and see the culture.
So people are like, they
happened to see what's new,
what's new in the world,
what's up and coming.
And that's a Deaf Nation, the expos.
Also, deaf art, there
are deaf artists
that use the language
to represent art.
So being able to see some
of the language meshed
with art is a great way to really
showcase the beauty of the language.
So before we talked about hashtag,
and that's the new
thing that's coming up.
There's one that's
hashtag why I sign.
There's another one, hashtag
dancing with the stars.
And, right, the audience
member said, yeah,
there is a hashtag AGB for AG Bell.
So before I had talked about AG
Bell how he wrote a very negative,
there was a negative article written
from the foundation
that was sent out.
And so there was a hashtag
there where people were speaking
in opposition trying to get the
message back to the foundation
that this is not the current
climate and the environment
in which we want the
language to disseminate.
And so we're looking around
saying, wow, all of these people
that are deaf, that are
using sign language.
So because of social media and
the technological advances,
we really are able to
spread our message.
So in historical mindset,
we had Veditz.
And then now we have
hashtags and vlogs in a way
to preserve the culture
and language.
I have some other comments and
some other stories, but if anybody
from the audience wanted to share.
So, yeah, a member of the
audience said, could you describe
about deaf schools and deaf
education and what happened
in Iowa and New Mexico as well.
Some of these schools
are being closed.
Do you mind to talk about that?
Yeah, we're noticing a lot
of deaf schools and a lot
of deaf school closures as well
as the decrease in numbers.
So people are trying to figure out
how do we keep them from closing?
How do we stress the importance
of these institutions and that
with LEAD K and other advocacy
groups, we're able to document
and support through justification
the need to keep these schools.
And it's important to keep.
In New Mexico, actually, they
are fighting it right now.
Pennsylvania School for the Deaf,
there's some issues
with the president.
And in Pennsylvania, they
have a superintendent,
and there's some issues
there with the politics
of how the school is being ran.
And understand this is
not just a domestic issue.
We're seeing it in Canada as well,
and across borders we're
seeing it in Portugal.
And there's a lot of deaf oppression
that's happening worldwide.
Coming from the audience
is, how about Sweden?
Have you heard anything
about Sweden?
Yeah, in Sweden there
are some people
that are experiencing oppression.
There was a videotape, something
had happened many years ago
that there was a big building
because of funding they
had bought it to replace
and demolish the deaf school.
But there still is some
socialization issues
with the deaf students.
Hang on one second while he's
getting the audience comment.
At deaf schools, there were
hearing teachers in Sweden.
You know, a lot of that
is happening in Sweden.
Seeing a lot of decrease in numbers
of deaf students and deaf schools.
So, yes, that is a way
to share information.
It's a way that Sweden has been
looking at some of our structures
and our systems in here of
how to use us as a model
for their school systems.
So, yeah, he had just mentioned
before about mainstream schools
which are just the
general public schools.
And a lot of hearing parents have
a predilection to put them in,
to put their deaf children
into schools.
They just think that
communication, you know,
they'll have an interpreter
should it should be fine.
But we're seeing now that a
deaf school is the best place.
It has the emersion, and it's the
best place for language acquisition.
Communication at a mainstream
school will have to be facilitated
through an interpreter
most of the time.
And at those schools, they're
not learning the cultures,
they're not having
that insemination.
But at deaf schools, they have the
deaf clubs, they're able to graduate
and learn and really feel that
they're a proud deaf person
and to have the language
and culture inside of them.
They don't feel dismissed
from society,
and as well as the language, they're
still able to acquire and to keep.
So now, again, I will stress
the importance of social media
and what its takeoff has meant.
Technology, what it has
done for the language
that we're forever able
to keep it with us?
>> I have a question
about deaf culture.
It's about the content
of deaf culture.
I was trained to be a
cataloger at a GPO when I worked
at GPO by a deaf cataloger.
And there was no interpreting
services there at the time.
And I had a wonderful experience
learning from her, and afterwards,
I wondered when I was
this training so good.
And I came to understand that
hearing people like to talk a lot.
There's a lot of BS.
And this is my question
as an outsider.
And I realized that
she taught me in a way
where her words were very important
and very short and concise.
So my question is, as a hearing
person, if I would listen
to deaf poetry, for example, or
deaf comedy, would it be something
that would be more compressed
or shorter in content
if you understand my question?
>> Max Williamson: Yeah, maybe
ask it again in a different way.
Yeah, if that's okay, ask it again.
>> My experience learning from a
deaf teacher as a hearing person was
that she was very concise
and to the point.
Very little BS.
And I'm wondering if I went to a
deaf cultural event like deaf comedy
or deaf poetry, whether the
expression would be that same way,
more concise and shorter
in terms of its content?
>> Max Williamson: Okay, so you
think that maybe like deaf culture
and the deaf language is more
concise and to the point on its own?
>> I don't know.
>> Max Williamson: Okay, sure.
[ Silence ]
The language is structured
differently.
There are different grammatical
rules in everything than in English.
So it does tend to start out with
the point and then it's explained.
So what is the point,
expansion, talk about what it is,
and then summarize the point.
But in terms of comedy and poetry,
there are some very specific
and idiosyncratic portions of that
that we can see that English has,
but to interpret between
them is different.
So the cultural part, understand
that deaf typically are more
direct, blunt, and to the point.
Whereas hearing try to kind of
obfuscate a little bit, maybe,
you know, oh, skirt around
the question or the point.
It's like, oh, a deaf
person said, wow,
it looks like you've gained weight.
You know, so there
could be that as well.
Does that make sense?
>> Yes. And I noticed the deaf
community here is very blunt
and to the point.
[ Silence ]
>> Max Williamson: Yes.
Yeah, and the point isn't
to insult or to be rude.
It's just to, it doesn't
offend us, it's just kind of.
In the deaf community when we
socialize with hearing people,
they'll look at us like, whoa, that
was way too blunt, way too direct.
But it's really just part of our
culture in how we communicate
and interact with each other.
Hearing people, they understand
me totally fine or with the things
that I might say to other deaf, they
could take it in a much better they
than when I communicate
with my hearing cohorts.
[ Background Sounds ]
So, yes. If you have a comment,
please come up to the front
because this is being recorded.
And so it's easier
for the camera to see.
[ Silence ]
>> So we have just mentioned before
about the preservation of language.
And why do we cherish the language?
I think before let's back up for a
little bit and talk about a child
that is born deaf to
hearing parents.
They don't have sign language.
So they're obviously going
to be on a language delay.
And we want these deaf children to
be able to acquire their language.
That's why they have to start
signing at an early age.
We had mentioned that there
was the new law that was passed
that immediately out of
hospital, a baby has to go
through a hearing test, and they
will be screened for hearing.
That way they can find what is
the best modality to expose them
to language at an early age.
Often, hearing parents,
they have hearing children.
It's not a problem.
Hearing children have
language acquisition
because of their hearing
parents, and they're able
to share the same language.
You know, if they don't
understand something, they can cry.
The hearing parents are able to
realize that there is some type
of communication with them.
We have started to see that they're
signing, hearing parents are signing
with their hearing babies.
Some of the basic signs.
Because they're seeing
that communication can
happen easier that way.
So it's another reason
why we cherish and want
to preserve our language.
>> Max Williamson:
Right, thank you for that.
It really is about the language.
There is one videotape
that I had seen
that juxtaposes two children
being raised in an environment.
One is exposed to sign
language and the other is not.
We see the success, they
graduate, have a job,
and are able to take off, while the
other one continues to struggle.
And that video really
emphasizes the importance
of early language exposure.
Any other questions?
[ Silence ]
Any comments?
>> Mekaella Vailu'u: So thank you.
This is the last event that we had.
But this is our last brown bag.
And if you would like to
come, everybody goes upstairs,
and we can eat together
and continue to socialize.
You're welcome to come and join
our table that everybody signs.
So thank you, everybody, for coming
and supporting the last
events that I've had.
This is the third.
And LCDA was a sponsor of
this, so thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
Also, if you have any
questions, feel free to go up
and ask a deaf person that
you work with [laughs].
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.